- [Interviewer] All right, Mike.
- Yes, sir.
- Mike, where did you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Mike] Rochester, New York.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about your family.
Did you have both your,
both your parents as a kid?
- My dad was in the army,
in I think World War II.
When he came out, he was so sick
he had to be placed in the VA
Hospital in Batavia, New York,
and he lived his life there,
and that's where he passed away at.
So as a child I was with my mom.
My mom was the only caretaker.
And she wasn't a very good mother.
I had to take care of eight
brothers and eight sisters,
at my young age at that time.
- [Interviewer] So 17 kids?
- No, eight all together.
- [Interviewer] Oh total of eight.
- Yeah, total of eight.
It would have been total of nine,
but my one brother died at an early age,
at 12 of leukemia.
He developed leukemia and passed away.
I started smoking at seven years old,
started drinking heavily.
My dad was an alcoholic.
My mom, we never could talk to her,
never associate with her half the time.
Then I got into, at that age I was,
she brought over guys who she
calls was uncles and stuff,
friends of the family.
And that's where it all
started, at the age of seven.
I started being molested by them,
and it went on for a few years,
and I kind of put up with it because,
I think she was getting paid for it,
to make money for the food and stuff.
And from there I got interested in,
I think that's what,
i think that's when I
made up my mind I was gay,
because I didn't know at that time
what to do, anything else about then,
and I started liking
younger boys in school.
And I quit school at an early age.
I didn't quit, I just never went.
Child Protective Service
was always trying to get me.
I, I lived off the
streets for a long time.
- [Interviewer] How far
did you go in school?
- I went to first school,
I think I went to like
fourth grade, fifth grade,
right around there.
It's when I didn't go no more,
'cause I ran away from home,
and lived on the streets
in Rochester, New York
with other homeless kids
who was into the sexy
scene with older guys
and things like that.
And I met a young,
young, young kid about my age,
and he was telling me about
these, well clients he had.
And I didn't know what
he meant by clients,
but he said sex parties and clients
that pay really good money.
So I started with him,
and he introduced me to
some of these clients.
And after a few years,
I didn't know that the
clients was actually judges,
lawyers, DA's, things
like that, business guys,
you know that pay for young boys.
And it went on from there,
then after I got a 17, 18, I met a guy.
He took me to a little town
where he owned a house and a farm.
And he was a sex partner at that time.
And he passed away after years,
after I was with him a few, few years.
I started working at a mug company.
By that time I was about 18, 19.
I met this young,
another youngster who was
at the time mowing the lawn
of the property that we lived on.
Well, we hooked up,
and that became my
partner for a long time.
And we used to go to,
what do you call it?
Music thing.
- [Interviewer] Concert.
- Concerts and stuff, a
lot of concerts and stuff.
And then I, after a while I met my wife.
My first wife I met, her name was Jolie.
And I met her walking (indistinct).
She was dressed in a nice gown.
At that time I was 19.
We met, I pulled over and talked to her.
We met, we got married shortly afterwards.
We was married for a month,
we got an annulment because
my little friend came over
and she kinda caught us.
She didn't know what was going on,
but she seen the light going off
and on in the bedroom of the house,
so she figured there
was something going on.
So she went and told the kid's parents,
and they forbid me to see him,
but we seen each other,
you know he stuck out,
we seen each other anyhow.
And so then I moved away,
and my second wife,
which was Marianne,
and she had four kids, three
boys and a little girl.
That's when the second incident started.
When we moved down to Florida,
and I met a few friends, I met
Frankie as a matter of fact,
and we moved to Florida.
With this other guy I
met in Medina, New York,
where I used to live, where we moved from,
he was gay
and he owned a lot of
property, a lot of money.
I got involved with him,
paying most of my rent,
my wife thought I was
out working at the time,
I was getting a lot of money from him.
And then we moved to Florida.
He moved us to Florida.
He bought us a house behind Taylor Park,
and we lived there for awhile.
And my youngest boy got in a
fight with the neighbor kid.
And that weekend, my boys
went away to a friend's house,
and somebody threw a (indistinct)
through the bedroom window
and burned up the house.
At that time, yeah, burned up the house.
So we moved from there.
And then I got to drinking more
and drugging more.
I was on drugs, using drugs,
but that's no excuse for what I did.
And I started fooling
around with her oldest boy.
We started fooling around.
And then it was, then it was
the next year younger boy,
we started fooling around,
and then we used to hang out,
I used to hang around with the gay bars
in Clearwater, Florida,
(indistinct) and stuff like that.
And we got involved in these hustlers,
who would be waiting at our vehicle
for when we came out to the gay bear joint
and pick us up.
Well, you know, we took them
home, had sex with them,
and went on for a long time.
And we paid them, we paid
for having sex with them.
And then they got involved
in robbing the place,
these hustlers, and they got caught.
And there was a new mayor
who was trying to be mayor of Clearwater.
And they put up a sting operation.
They came and arrested us.
That was the first time I got arrested.
Then it was called the
Clearwater 27, or 28.
And that was back in the 90's.
And it was in papers,
everything else like that.
And we all got arrested.
Everybody got probation for
it, 'cause they had money.
I didn't have money, so I
went to prison for 10 years.
I got automatically prison sentence.
And nobody else did, they
got two years probation.
Everybody that was involved in that.
And at that time there was bankers,
well-known bankers involved in it
and stuff like that.
That's a story that you
look up in Clearwater,
it's in there.
And then they dropped
the charge on me on that,
so they went after my boys.
They figured that they could get me
for a higher charge if they go for
a custodian of a parent with the boys,
so that's what they did.
- [Interviewer] How old were the boys?
- My boys was 13 and 14 at the time.
And they wouldn't say
nothing for a long time,
but then they got them to talk.
And I admitted to everything,
went to prison.
From prison, when I first
got in prison I was scared,
but I was honest and open with everybody.
When they asked me what I was in for,
I told them.
I never lied to any of the inmates,
anybody in there, the guards, anybody.
I figured if this is the
time for my life to end,
it's gonna end here.
And I didn't have no problem with prison.
Then I thought I was getting out,
and they hit me with a Jimmy Rice case,
which is a Civil Commitment Center.
And I went there for eight
years, intense counseling.
You couldn't come out of the place,
you was locked down.
I was locked down for eight years,
and I had to go to counseling
all day long, nothing else,
intense counseling.
And I didn't think I was
ever gonna get out of there
because they said most
people die in there,
they never get out of Jimmy Rice.
But I had a lawyer,
Janine Colon from Tampa,
who was a real good lawyer,
got two state doctors to come and see me
for like four years in a row,
and they had approve to let me out.
And both doctors finally after four years
approved I was fit for society,
and I was a changed man.
And that's where my life went.
Well, there's a lot of
names I cannot mention
because New York, if I mention names,
I don't know what could happen with me,
so just protect myself.
But all this from Child
Protective Service,
I was molested, I was a hustler,
and all that could be
proven by the reports
in New York from Child
Protective Service and all that.
- [Interviewer] So your
interest in young boys-
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Lasted for how long?
- It lasted for, since I was 18 to,
well to, up to eight years ago,
until I realized there was an age
they couldn't give consent under 18
to really have sex and everything else.
When I first pursued
it when I was younger,
you know 'cause what happened to me,
I thought it was fine.
I never forced anybody or nothing,
this was always, you know,
what I used a lot of pot to get 'em high,
'cause kids back then
like pot and alcohol.
And served it with them
and they were okay to different sex acts
and stuff like that.
And I thought I wasn't doing
nothing wrong at the time,
but I was really hurting 'em, you know?
And not only did I hurt them,
I hurt the generation on,
their family and on and on.
So, you know, I went to counseling,
and I found all this out about me.
So now, yes, I'm still gay,
I still like men,
but it's older men, more my age,
maybe a little bit younger, whatever.
And I'd like to meet somebody that
don't mind what I did.
It's not right what I did, but,
I'm not giving excuse, I did what I did,
and it was wrong and I learned that.
But I want somebody
who knows my background
so we can go ahead and live our lives
the way we wanna live,
you know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] Do you feel
remorse over what you did?
- Yes, I do, very much.
I live with it every night, every day.
And I feel more,
because when I was locked up,
my wife is a deaf mute,
she can't hear or talk,
she was living in an apartment
in St. Petersburg, Florida,
with a roommate who was
a deaf mute, a teacher,
used to be a teacher, was
selling drugs out of high school,
he got caught so he got arrested,
and he was banned from the school.
But a year after that,
just recently, in 2011,
he was driving through
my wife's neighborhood,
and we don't know what
he was doing over there,
and just happened to go crazy
and kicked in the door
and stabbed my wife to
death and her roommate.
And he went on, cops
were trying to get him,
it took an hour for them to get him,
but he ran over a 12-year
old kid trying to kill him.
He ran over a porch for a neighbor woman
trying to hurt them.
He went around the
corner, broke in a motel,
beat the old man, old lady up
in the head with a hammer,
put them in intensive care.
So he did a lot of damage before
they caught him in an hour.
Now he's serving four
life sentences for that.
But I feel bad because, I feel,
I have to live with that because
if I didn't do what I do
I would have been home with her,
maybe I could have prevented that.
I could hear the guy coming,
I could have did
something to prevent that,
but her kids hate me now because of it.
They said "If you would
have not did what you did,
"you would have been home,
"things might have been different."
I live with a lot of guilt,
but I'm learning,
I learned to take one day at a time
to live with what I
did to go through life.
- [Interviewer] Do you feel like
what happened to you as a young man,
as a young boy kind of caused this?
- I think that nobody's born gay,
nobody's born, I don't think that.
I think what happened in life,
early on in life, you're taught things
and you take those things,
and you learn things,
and what you can make out of it.
Yeah, I think what happened
to me when I was younger
built me up to, because
I never thought that.
I'm the only one in my family,
my family don't have
nothing to do with me.
My brothers, because I'm a sex,
a sexual predator.
And because of what I did
they don't wanna have
nothing to do with me.
I lost a lot, so I have to live with it.
- [Interviewer] You lost a lot of friends
because of this?
- Lost a lot of friends,
lost a lot of-
- [Interviewer] Family.
- Family.
Lost my mom when I was locked up.
Me and my mom was, my mom didn't really,
after she got older and she understood
what she did and what I did,
we talked and she said she
should have been a better mother
but she didn't know how to be
a better mother at the time
'cause she was young.
My dad and her,
my mom was like 14 and 15 when my,
my dad was an older man,
and they got married.
At that age back then you
could get married at that age.
So she didn't know how to raise,
how to take care of kids.
My dad was sexually active with her,
and they had kids every year almost.
So she didn't really
know how to be a mother,
nobody taught her nothing.
Being a kid herself with an older man,
she didn't know.
- [Interviewer] And what's
your biggest regret?
- My biggest regret is
messing up those kids' lives,
that ruined their lives forever.
And I hope they someday can
forgive me for what I did.
Not forgave what I did,
but just forgive me for what I did.
You know, go on with their lives
and have a family and be okay.
That's my biggest regret.
- [Interviewer] What emotion
do you deal with most
because of this?
- When all this went
down and everything else,
I was diagnosed as paranoid schizophrenia.
I'm on my medication, I
take medication every day.
The thing I really regret is
to not having a normal life
like some kids have,
you know growing up to be successful.
You know, when you go to prison
and everything else, you have
to take any job you can get
and people would talk down on you,
and people see you
and they know you're sex offenders.
They just, people nowadays are very,
rather than the community helping us
to get up on our feet once
we got the education we have
to help us do better,
I mean sex offenders are
known as the dirt of the dirt.
I mean a murderer could murder somebody
and live next door to you
without you even knowing it,
not have to register or nothing.
But a sex offender, we pay for
it for the rest of our lives.
We gotta register, we gotta make sure
we don't go in places where kids are at
and everything else like that.
So we gotta be a lot of careful.
A lot of jobs, we can't get good jobs.
We have to work whatever
we can get to survive
the rest of our lives.
- [Interviewer] And what
was the most important
lesson you've learned?
- The most important lesson I learned is
to, when you feel that
something ain't right
when you're younger, that
somebody's taking advantage of you
or somebody's touching you or something,
go to somebody right away.
And that's what I should have done.
I should have went to
somebody who will listen,
who will listen.
You know, an officer or somebody,
another adult away from my family
that would have maybe got
me the help at that time
and guided me the right way.
- [Interviewer] Well
you had your own mother,
and your mother wasn't...
- No, my mother wasn't,
half the time we didn't talk to my mother.
My mother was like,
she didn't care how late
we were out at night,
who we were with.
Guys would bring us home,
and she'd be nice to 'em,
"Oh yeah, thank you, thank you."
And they'd ask to pick up me the next day,
"Oh sure, sure."
She didn't know these guys
so it was like no parenting at
all, no guidance or nothing.
- [Interviewer] What's
the craziest escapade
you involved yourself in?
- The craziest thing I
could say I did in my life
was when I was in New York
and I had two vehicles at the time,
an El Camino and a Camaro.
Pretty new, both of them.
I had a friend who was gay too,
about my age, he had a driver's license.
We got in a car after drinking all day,
we put my kids in the car,
my wife's kids, you know, the boys.
And driving down the back road racing
and everything else like that.
We came up over the hill
and I landed my Camaro
in the back of my El Camino.
And the El Camino went towards the canal
that was full of water.
A piece of pipe held it from going over.
They probably would have drownded,
and we went through the woods,
and when we came to
we had the kids run over
to the other side of a bridge
because we knew we could get in trouble
for having kids in the car
while we were driving crazy.
There was a witness to it,
and we got arrested for DUI, both of us.
We went to court.
But before we went to court,
when the troopers took us to the hospital
to get blood work, they
took it from him first,
and before they got me,
a friend of mine heard it on the monitor,
police monitor, that I was being taken
there for a blood test,
he came down to the hospital
and told me to go to the bathroom.
I went to the bathroom and I drank Visine.
He told me to drink the bottle of Visine.
I drank it and I did a blood test,
and he showed up he was legally drunk,
and I showed up, I didn't have no alcohol
in my system at all.
So I walked away free,
no tickets or nothing.
- [Interviewer] So Visine does this?
- Yeah, Visine did it, yeah.
That was the craziest thing I ever did.
I said "Am I gonna die
drinking this stuff?
"What are you trying to get me to do?"
- [Interviewer] How much of
your questionable behavior
was fueled by alcohol or drugs?
- I don't think alcohol,
yeah, it fueled it because
the behavior was there
not being taught right.
It just helped, it just helped,
how can I say it?
It just helped me be more comfortable
and easier to do things that I did
than otherwise I would before.
Like now, Frankie would tell you,
I know Frankie for years, since the 80's,
I'm very, when it comes to somebody
that I know is gay that I like,
I won't go up and talk to them,
ask them if they wanna go out
or anything or if they
want a drink, anything,
I'm like a shy person.
But when, I quit drinking
after all this happened,
after all of this
happened, back in the 90s,
I quit drinking and drugging.
I haven't touched a drink or a drug since,
and I won't.
I want nothing.
And I just, it feels like I died inside
because a lot of people
says that too that know me
because I'm not as easy going and friendly
and outgoing like I used to be.
So the alcohol did a lot of that for me.
Hid a lot of feelings
and stuff in the drugs.
- [Interviewer] All right, Mike,
well thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- You're welcome.
- [Interviewer] And good
luck with staying on track
and I hope you stay this way.
Stay out of trouble.
- I'm fighting it every day.
I'm gonna try.
Take one day at a time.
- [Interviewer] Is it
still a battle for you?
- No, because what I learned
in Civil Commitment Center
I paid attention to,
and what I'm learning out here
is that everyday gets easier.
Everyday gets easier.
You just gotta take one day at a time.
- [Interviewer] Did the therapy help?
- Yeah, therapy helped a lot.
Therapy helps a lot.
If you put yourself to it.
If you just sit there and don't listen,
don't pay attention,
you gotta put yourself through it.
You gotta participate.
And it helps.
I'm telling you it helps a lot.
It works very much.
They say sex offenders can't be cured,
but I'm telling you I don't have no desire
of any young kids now,
anything else for that.
But I have desires of older people now,
things like that.
So it really works.
Therapy does help sexual predators
and sexual offenders if they
really apply themselves to it.
- [Interviewer] Mike,
well thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- You're welcome.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.
- Thank you.